waiting
to be sure that i'm actually live and
then fiddle with the
framing and the lighting like i do at
the start of
every single stream that i have ever
done
ever i hope this doesn't get
all stupid on me the way the last one
did
waiting for confirmation that folks can
see me hey
hi kara
oh good people can see me yay okay i
need to
soften this so yes
as i predicted uh
i'm gonna be fiddling with the lighting
for
a minute or so so
bear with me i'm trying to do this
without having to get up from the chair
because i
am really
really lazy well if we go with that
how does that end up looking
uh yeah yeah i can live with that
do that a little bit get myself more
centered
because i'm a vain vain [ __ ]
i'm ready for my close-up missed it
[Laughter]
hope everybody's doing all right uh
how's tricks i i don't turn tricks
anymore it's too cold
uh
more more light
ah hi meg
cheeky
hotter than ever that flattery will get
you
somewhere i'm not sure where but i'll
get you somewhere
uh i'm i'm a little bit um
goofy tonight i am i may have spiked to
this
more than had been my uh initial
intention
and actually since meg's in the chat you
can thank meg for the lips
uh and also the eye shadow
what am i drinking tonight tonight it is
a warm apple cider
and mold mead which is
uh a glorious thing
can you impersonate the adults from
charlie brown
i can but like i
i cannot help but wonder like is this
something that you're going to
clip and then
use out of context for something that's
screw it
up
favorite christmas on carol the bells
that one's easy
uh so much for a nice drink of christmas
water
it's it's water it's slightly discolored
but it's water
[Music]
oh can you now meg
yeah i bet i doubt that's apple cider
why do you doubt that what other kind of
cider would it be
i said i added other stuff to it is
there another kind of cider besides
apple that i'm unaware of that you're
presuming
cover your mouth that's my advice i
prefer to make use of my mouth for the
benefit of all
this is off to a good start
have you seen moonlight
yes i understand why it won a lot of
awards
that is all i have to say about it have
you seen krampus nope
nope i have not a lot of the um
quirkier pics for christmas movies
especially stuff that's out
more recently like krampus or rare
exports and stuff like that i'm like i
i don't know seriously though how do you
how do you dance the trans-siberian
orchestra version of carol the bells
i could probably dig up the video of me
dancing to that in high school
uh should be called council of geeks
flirts with the chat
you know what i think i probably will
name one of the
live streams that in the future
that is all oh that's all you have to
say about that meg i doubt that for some
reason
i might cover your mouth for the
impression it'll undermine any attempt
at lip syncing
ah i didn't know i did know what you
meant but i was just i was
having fun with it worst christmas movie
you've ever watched
um okay so heads up i can already tell
i'm not gonna be able to keep up with
the chat
so if i miss your question and it's
scrolled past
it's okay to ask again just don't spam
it repeatedly okay just give me
give me a chance at it uh worst
christmas movie i've ever watched
the thing is since i'm generally someone
who goes out of the way to avoid
bad movies or movies that i think will
be bad i have not taken in as much
bad media as i think is standard for
someone who makes their living on the
internet
that having been said it was probably
last christmas
dear god why
what was the oscar-winning film that
made you so bored you had to watch the
prom i am
still choosing to not answer that
question because it feels
annoyingly loaded to even try and tackle
and i know if
i know if i answer that people will ask
why you are
were bored and i just i just don't want
to have that conversation
i just don't forgive me for asking
but are you against marrying on
principle um
kinda so all right
so here's my thing with marriage
broadly speaking i think it's a really
bad idea
i say that as someone who has been
married um
and and i don't regret being married
partially because i actually had a
very amicable amicable divorce it was
about
the smoothest divorce i've ever heard of
anyone happening after 12 years of being
married
but i
in my opinion oh forgot something
in my opinion the fact that
being married makes breaking up
exponentially harder
that fact alone outweighs most of the
scant
benefits that it grants
i just i don't think it's worth it that
having been said i don't
judge people who get married i don't
judge people who want to get married i
don't think you're stupid for getting
married but you're asking am i against
it on principle yeah kinda
like not harsh enough that i'm gonna be
like oh married people
but you know i don't support it
sorry you can still have a party
have a commitment ceremony have the
party have the celebration of
wanting to have a life together that's
fine it's it's the legal
proceedings i have an issue with not
like the ceremony have a ceremony have a
party
like you don't even need a reason i
support parties
mary mary something miss thank you adam
greatly appreciated uh did you watch the
grinch live on nbc
no
that that's not a thing i refuse to
believe that that is a thing that exists
you're messing with me i don't believe
you
and then are you against yourself
getting married thank you for clarifying
well yes
since i'm against marriage in general
yeah i am against uh
the idea that i will get married again
who would rather play on broadway
jack skellington be pt barnum or sweeney
todd
okay i i gotta i gotta go through these
jack like i would happily play any or
all three
jack's a little emo um
let's see barnum
see like here's the tough thing i feel
like i'd have a little more fun playing
pt barnum
but like if i'm if i'm splitting hairs
which is what i have to do going between
these three
there is that niggling thing in the back
of my head like i wish this was an
original character and i wasn't
mythologizing that man
might have to go with sweeney todd
better to be a killer than to
mythologize
the real pt barnum there's a hot take
uh
careful talking about my boyfriend jack
look meg
meg i love jack
i'm just saying for my own taste
he's a little emo what
have i done
i mean a little bit give me that
if that's your thing awesome but like
come on now
maybe you should have cast you as the
grinch and jessie gender as max
that would have been something just
dropped in to say happy
yule and it's 1am have a good night have
a nice stream thank you elfie you have a
good night
thanks for stopping in uh
active chat you sounded beautiful
oh thank you oh see now that like
meg's actually like a professional
singer so her saying that i said like i
appreciate it when anybody says they
sound good
because ego but you know
the source can impact the the amount of
inflation
uh have you seen
mrs santa claus it's a made for tv
musical starring angela lansbury
no i was unfamiliar
can you grin like the grinch no i can't
the the way that that you have to do
that is it's not just that the grin is
big you have to bring like the center of
your mouth
down at the same time the corners go up
i can't
i can't i can't get that combination the
center of my mouth goes up
when i smile and i can't i can't bring
it back down to really emphasize the
difference
thoughts on spearhead and space it's
fine
i feel that way about a lot of the quote
unquote
iconic uh classic air doctor who
episodes can you whistle or hum
something from hamilton
here's the thing i think that's just as
likely to get me
flagged as actually singing it is
um
trying to think what i would even
whistle or hum
um oh god i'm drawing a blank all of a
sudden
sorry your boy you people love to put me
on the spot and just leave me hanging
like a corpse on a jibbet that's sweetly
morbid for you can you impersonate the
grinch
well see that depends on which grinch
we're talking about
because there's the um
uh boris karloff grinch
i must find some way to keep christmas
from
coming for tomorrow i know
all those googles and boys will wake
bright and early i can do him
cause he grew up on that the jim carrey
grinch
i first of all i don't know it as well
cause i don't like that movie all that
much
there are decent moments there's like
his whole um
when he's getting dressed and stuff like
ooh
ah that [ __ ] i'm not going
so i mean i guess kinda
he's just kind of he's got that voice
that you get when you have
fake teeth in that a lot of actors end
up with
seven o'clock wallowing shelf pity
dinner with my shelf i can't put that
off again
you know it i get so i guess maybe i can
i don't know
you make the call
what's going on and merry christmas yes
merry christmas indeed logan
oh oh carolyn did we have to snipe
somebody out of here
ah yes yes we did good call good catch
nicely done have a treat
uh
uh what are your thoughts on beavis and
butthead to america
i have never seen it i never really went
for bbs and butthead
and i was like right in the age like
everybody my age thought it was the
funniest crap
ever i just um
like i can impersonate them but that's
about all i've got
yeah cool fire cool
shut up beavis so
like i could do that and that would give
me a laugh but
have you seen the the netflix cartoon
held hilda i've seen season one i
haven't seen season two yet and i won't
for a bit because
that's the next thing i'm gonna watch
with my kid now that we've finished the
first season of the owl house yes there
will be
a review of the first season of the owl
house up in the break room
i'm i'm really trying to catch up on
other stuff uh the break
i'm getting stuff up for the break room
is is
tangential to a lot of other stuff i'm
trying to get
finished off south parker family guy ah
i don't really care for either at this
point
i suppose south park is still
trying to have a point
except that its point is usually it's
stupid to have opinions
and if you believe in anything you're an
idiot so
is it worse to have no point
which is where family guy's at now or to
have a point that's not a
point i think anyone should be making
i don't know i honestly don't know
i did used to i used to enjoy both at
various points but
i grew up and they didn't so do you sell
a favorite toy or gift you received as a
child the
the chris the collective christmas i
remember best
what i would have been
seven i think um
because that was the christmas of
nintendo
because it wasn't just a nintendo system
it was a bunch of games um you know the
ones you expect
like um super mario brothers but
i got i got two different
ninja turtle games the nintendo ninja
turtle games the first two
um i got um the duck
you know ducktales chippendales rescue
rangers and
i got a subscription to nintendo power
as a christmas gift as well
that was a good year that was good time
have you seen any of the carry-on films
nope i know them by reputation
only
ah
a bunch of games spoiled but we still
love you
look meg i was an only child
and while i was not an only grandchild i
was the only
local grandchild so
my grandparents honestly spoiled me a
lot more than my mother did
cause they had other grandkids but they
were down in florida
they'd spoil them remotely but i was
right there
i benefited greatly from being the only
local grandchild
good stuff why aren't you wearing an
ugly christmas jumper or sweater in the
u.s for this
for the season um i suppose i could have
i only really have one that i think
qualifies and it's got a stain on it
which i suppose
i shouldn't care about if it's an ugly
sweater but i don't know i feel
weird about wearing something stained do
you put candy canes on your christmas
tree no i don't
santa puts the candy canes on the
christmas tree after the presents are
dropped off that's how that works
i envy that you were an only child i got
stuck with four other siblings
i mean i ended up with step siblings
around 13
but only child man i recommend it
have you seen doom patrol i still have
not like the thing is
i i'm probably not gonna have time
to even try and work on
things for fun um
until february like i'm having trouble
even getting back into and finishing up
the the watchmen
series because like i've got i've got a
major video project that i'm trying to
get done for this month and then
major um heavy workload projects our
video projects are on hold for a bit
until i get the book finished
and then once that's done i really need
to catch my ass up on my commission
stuff because i'm
i am embarrassingly far behind on that
so once
all that's done
if i'm lucky by around march
maybe i can start looking into
watching stuff on my own for fun
does your daughter believe in santa yes
she still does
which is nice we we weren't sure if she
still would this year but she still does
which is sweet thank you very much
randomness not gonna lie i was a little
underwhelmed by the loki trailer i
thought it'd be
more in the style of the war master or
missy big finish
uh see that'll teach you to have
expectations
when you have hopes you're just setting
yourself up to be let down
expect everything to suck i think you'll
just be pleasantly surprised when it
doesn't
i'm only half kidding
you make a really sexy wonder woman
thank you
folks can hop on to uh my tick tock for
that including a flat out thirst trap
yeah i'm not even going to apologize for
that
ah thank you very much
uh d duvall or is it de duval
i don't know i still think 90s simpsons
is the funniest tv
uh to ever be created agree or disagree
what's your funniest tv show
see i think trying to label anything the
funniest is always going to
be a bit of a land mine because there
are a few things more subjective than
humor um anyone who wants to say that
they think that is the funniest i'm not
really gonna disagree with that but
humor is so
personal do you have a favorite queen
from six
yet um
yes i do um sorry give me a sec
hair is pretty thank you meg best
version of a christmas carol the muppets
um i'm not kidding
so my favorite um
queen from six hold on i've
i'm trying to remember the actual name i
could tell you what number she is in the
order but i'm trying to actually
recall the name all of a sudden and
suddenly it is slipping
away from me
ah it's number five
is what it is hey that's embarrassing
their straps are the best they are
they're annoying to make though
because i'm really picky about it
looking just right i had to reshoot that
a lot more times than i want to admit
uh to quote kratos from god of war
accept disappointment and
you never will um
your hair got longer during quarantine
well yeah
i haven't been cutting it so it would uh
they're putting when love is gone back
into
the muppet christmas carol oh cool
catherine howard thank you
thank you very i knew i knew it was
catherine started with an h but i wasn't
drawing the name howard
thank you thank you very much
uh the george c scott version is my
favorite but my bets is very close
second the george c scott version is
legit
there's a i mean there's a lot of good
ones
happy life like oh happy life day
that calls for a drink
uh
should there ever be a version of a
christmas carol where all the names are
changed
similar to how names were changed when
adapting
hamlet to the lion king
what would be the point
i mean there's no reason why you
couldn't arguably that
scrooge did that
but what would that be an aid of i guess
i'm not
clear as to why you'd feel the need to
do that
other than setting it in modern day and
the names are outdated
i mean that's kind of it
love muppet treasure island too oh
that's a good one
shiver my timber shiver my soul
oh good stuff
um what's your least favorite
least favorite christmas song ooh
i don't know like um
i don't know because like it's the kind
of thing that i i
i will tune out if i hear it so
trying to think of what are the ones i
don't like oh
you know it would be it'd be the novelty
[ __ ] like i saw mommy kissing santa
claus or i want a hippopotamus for
christmas
although i will defend that one to a
certain extent because one of my burly
friends
makes very humorous use of that song but
outside of that context i'm like
no i said no c
shanties uh this is more of a rock remix
so
it's fine uh have you seen the
2018 the grinch from illumination i did
it was boring as [ __ ]
there you go that's my one curse for the
stream
i say that but by the time i finish this
i'll probably be swearing more
um speaking so okay
speaking of swearing for folks who don't
already know if you're not already
following jessie gender
on youtube first of all you should she's
great
she has a christmas special uh episode
or sorry holiday special episode
coming out on friday which
there are a lot of cameos in i would be
like
all mysterious maybe i'm in it except
like
i'm on the thumbnail image so obviously
i'm in it
but the reason i bring this up the
reason i thought to bring this up
because
of um mentioning swearing is
later on this month i think
like maybe even to cap off the year
she's got a blooper reel
from all the footage sent to her from
the various people who cameoed
and she let me get an early look at that
blooper reel
because she knows i don't swear on the
channel
and given how much of the blooper reel
has taken up with me
swearing she wanted to be sure i was
okay with that going live
so look forward to towards the end of
the year me cursing up an absolute storm
because
trying to get me to work scripted lines
goes very badly
uh
let's see something my dad and i talked
about the other day is we're confused on
why hollywood keep making
live-action remates remakes it's not
making any money it is though
it actually is if it didn't make money
they'd stop
it does and actually in the case of the
disney live action remakes
some of those were the biggest films
released in their respective years the
beauty and the beast one made over a
billion dollars
they do make money depressingly so
i'm hoping that mulan and the reaction
to that might be the start of things
turning against this but no they've been
successful they would have stopped long
before if they hadn't been
see that's the thing if you find
yourself asking
why are they doing that that doesn't
make money look into it odds are it
probably does
because if it didn't they wouldn't keep
doing it because
there are things that'll be one-offs
um where a uh
you know a studio or whatever we'll sign
off on something and go oh well that
didn't work but you know what they don't
do it again after that
no swearing you mean you try to be kids
friendly i mean
um i guess the thing is like i
definitely don't make any of my content
to appeal to children but i also
i don't i don't want to alienate um
anyone who's sensitive about swearing i
don't feel like
me cursing is worth um
turning off certain segments of my
audience
that said i swear a heck of a lot in my
day-to-day life as you will
see on the blooper reel when that goes
up
hmm i haven't seen mulan is it still
costing extra no i think it's just part
of
uh disney plus streaming now how far
away from your avatar season 2 review
i'm about halfway through the season
so i don't know
however long it takes me to get through
the latter half
don't don't try and get me to commit to
deadlines
uh other people you you fools
uh what are you drinking i am drinking
warm apple cider and mold mead
favorite and list and least favorite
christmas movie
i love actually has become the christmas
tradition movie
for me least favorite
i don't know probably something that i
forgot i watched because my least
favorite would actually probably be
something boring
because while last christmas was bad
it's fun to talk about
because of how bad it is wow
uh
uh there needs to be a doctor who
christmas episode about
the about the what about the gavel goat
i'm missing something there okay
you're looking lovely tonight thank you
don't try to make me comment
on deadlines you sound like my you sound
like my audio drama actors
legit as someone who's done a bit of
audio drama acting this year
for nothing that's out and so i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna
spell that it's not my place to do so um
yeah no legit uh honestly legit for
any actor that's thinking about getting
actors for
for voice work if they're recording for
home
from home they're setting their own
schedule there's your mistake
you force them into a studio that you've
rented you can make them do the work
uh you were nominated for a tony what's
your reaction
i'm not on broadway how the hell did
that happen that's my reaction
uh how much of classic who have you seen
and what ones do you want to see next
i don't even i'd like i've probably seen
about
half of what is available
that's a rough guess i don't know i'm
not like going through a checklist
gavel is a swedish city where they have
a tradition of putting
up a big goat statue there's also a
tradition of people trying to destroy it
sounds like people
uh have you seen the classic doctor who
blooper
where tom baker swears at k9 because he
never knows the answer when it's
important
i feel like i've seen that once i think
it's been a while though
you weren't nominated for for a tony for
your performance in sweeney todd what's
your reaction
there's a hole in the world like a great
black pit and it's filled with people
it's filled with [ __ ]
the woman of the world inhabited
but not for long
i've slowly grown to hate a christmas
story it's not
bad just overexposed um i just can't
get away from the leg lamp um the thing
was i never saw that one as a kid i
didn't see that one until i was an adult
actually same with the um stop motion
uh rank and bass stuff i never saw any
of that as a kid
the ranking bass um holiday special that
i grew up on
was twas the night before christmas
which was
hand-drawn 2d animated the one with the
mice
it's got really sweet songs that one i
feel like it's under-remembered
there's more to the world than meets the
eye
it's good stuff
uh which is the better water eggnog or
mulled wine
that is mood dependent
you can whistle or hum you'll be back ms
wiggin wolf you're very into
getting me to sing and i'm i'm not doing
it enough for you on my own
uh christmas wishes come true
if you were to land a part in a
midsummer night's dream would you rather
play puck
or ladies designing a puck
puck always always and forever because
you cannot tell me i'm not allowed to
gender
[ __ ] a fairy i do not have to present
masculine to play puck
thank you for coming to my ted talk
do you like the uh sp the scp animation
here on youtube
like the rubber dr bob or lord
bung uh also will your book be available
in germany
i don't know any of those youtubers i
don't know what scp
animation is thank you very much for the
super chat
i really do appreciate it will the book
be available in germany i
think so um i'm not that far
yet uh it should be available in
european
um territories my last one was
so i think so it's not gonna be
available
in german i i don't have a translator i
trust
uh
people who have only the film version of
sweeney todd
don't understand how darkly funny it is
on stage
at its best yeah it can be quite darkly
funny
some some of the humor i like
some of the stuff with toby honestly on
stage makes me
uncomfortable i was in
midsummer nights ones playing a
mechanical those are fun too
but i want puck i want him so bad
shall we their fond pageant see lord
what fools these
mortals be
i want to play puck and i just want to
mess with people so
much
what's your favorite mythical creature
in any mythology
um
[Music]
huh i don't know i'm always partial to a
good dragon
uh if can do scary or horror moments
in marvel comics uh or in kid shows
i'm the problem with that kind of stuff
is i can only speak to my own experience
and i feel like i haven't kept up with a
lot of that stuff and so if and
so like when i did like a while back i
did
lists of movies that always make me cry
or movies that always freak me out it
was very personal to me
i didn't try and make an argument as to
why these are
scary to other people because i know if
i tried to make it sound more objective
then people would come at me with a
million examples of stuff that i hadn't
seen and didn't know what i feel like me
trying to cite
um scary kids material is gonna suffer
from the same thing
i can only speak to stuff that i've seen
that's aimed at kids that i think is
scary or what have you um but i know and
you know comments on any video like that
there's gonna be five million things
that i have
never seen um
vera i think snow should play puck
carowind
i would argue that snow is puck
and anyone who has ever seen me host a
burlesque show
knows what that means and anyone else
well you miss a good show
what's the story behind the weapons um
they're mine and i own them and they're
on a rack
there isn't really a story they are a
thing that i own
no just like these are things that i own
uh if you were gonna make a list of
movies you hate but everyone else
loves which would be number one ferris
bueller the shining
probably the shining because i feel like
more people are on my side about ferris
bueller
so the shining would be the hotter take
uh which version of dragons asian
medieval fantasy see
you're not going to nail me down on that
because i love the flexibility of a
dragon
you know what's crazy to me there's tons
of movies and shows etc based on greek
and norse mythology and yet
little to nothing about celtic mythology
or native american
yeah nice rack oh well played
pirates um
yeah i feel like you're more likely to
get
celtic uh iconography
or bits and pieces of it but it's rarely
adapted as like
let's tell this story but now to be
fair part of that has to do with the
fact that we have
better record of what
the greek and norse myths
were the thing about trying it
and again you there's certainly more
that can be done to take inspiration
from but the thing about trying to do
native american or celtic mythology is
it was largely an
oral tradition which means first of all
it's not
uniform it varies all over the place
because the oral tradition dictates that
it changes and evolves over time
and so wherever it's being told it's
going to be a little different than
where it's told other places
there isn't a definitive version the way
that there
is with greek mythology with north smith
although honestly not even with greek or
norse mythology because a lot of those
are adapting earlier mythologies anyways
but because we have
written works to consult for those it's
a lot easier to go to them
and not feel like you're screwing it up
because if you pick
even if you like go to a direct source
for a
celtic myth you pick
this is the story i'm going to tell
there's going to be
other people from the region steeped in
that
lore from that culture who are going to
say no you did it wrong because their
version doesn't match the one you did
it's
a much more of a minefield to try and do
that which i think is why
it shows up in very scant a very like
background or world-building elements
kind of way as opposed to
we're flat-out telling the story from
this culture
and from this folklore and mythology if
that makes sense
what's your favorite animated film and
why oh god damn i don't know
like you need to realize i love
animation so much i don't really
distinct i don't
i don't and sometimes practically for
the purposes of movie lists i do but in
my head i don't
segment animated movies away from live
action
so i don't like have a separate list in
my head
and summer wars would be right up there
i'm not sure it'd be number one though i
don't know
if you ever review glee
i can't even finish the rest of that
question if i ever review
glee
[Music]
you're funny
ah japanese media loves
lifting from christian mythology to
reckless abandon
i mean a lot of christianity is already
a couple together of a bunch of other
stuff that's been mashed up so why the
heck not
uh i played nick bottom in a college
shakespeare production and the director
told hippolyta to lust
after me ooh
as if i was her submissive toy oh dear
yeah are you aware of the egyptian
mythology around horus and set
i've i've known it
um i i
i need a refresher on it i have heard it
i have been aware of it
previously i i couldn't i couldn't
recite it off top of my head favorite
favorite dance style i don't know
move the way that feels right pole
um would you watch hell bent on loop
before you review glee um
i might not just for the sake of
experiencing a different kind of
pain but i'm
like look i will have
out next year
my third video dedicated explicitly to
hell bent
i have voluntarily re-watched hell bent
an unsettling number of times given how
much i
hate it i will never
voluntarily watch glee
pay me
uh oh thank you carowind discord
uh let's see
so i give me a second folks i'm going to
be off
the um the chat
and a little bit while i pop on over to
the discord and grab
those questions because the discord is a
patreon perk and there is a channel in
the discord for
uh the live stream that guarantees i
will answer questions if asked so
one more reason to sign up for the
patreon if you haven't already okay i'm
done whoring myself give me a second
okay um
favorite lesser-known christmas movie um
i'm not sure i've really got a
lesser-known christmas movie
that i'm particularly fond of
i i kind of go in for the standards
i mean the lesser-known christmas
special i really like i already
mentioned the rankin and bass was the
night before christmas which
is usually forgotten um versus all their
other stuff
have you seen klaus i've not i've been
meaning to but i have yet to get around
to it
excluding pixar which animated disney
movies have the best and worst animation
regardless of the quality of the movies
themselves
first of all i'm glad you excluded pixar
because i completely deal with them
separately i never lump the two together
because like i i feel fundamentally the
difference in
approach between disney and pixar so
best and worst
animation ooh
that is trying to name a
best animation like visual stylings
um for disney
that's that feels almost impossible i
think it's going to come down to a
matter of taste and which style appears
to you
appeals to you the most because you know
how do you compare something
like fantasia to
sleeping beauty to the lion king to
moana
they're all freaking gorgeous in their
own ways
um as for what has the worst animation
um probably something like the
aristocats
there was a phase where they kind of
went for this sort of sketchy
look um like it was almost kind of half
finished
i never thought it looked very good
uh that's probably what i go with for
that
a charlie brown christmas versus muppet
christmas carol both are great of course
but if you could only watch one each
year which would it be
oh
probably muppet christmas carol because
i enjoy singing along to the songs
but oh that's tough is die hard a
christmas movie
no and here's why
in my mind a christmas movie is not
simply a movie that takes place
at christmas it is a movie
whose plot would have to fundamentally
change if it was set
at any other time of year besides
christmas
the only impact that the christmas
timing
has on die hard is superficial
the ho ho gags
some of his lines the fact that there's
a christmas party but the thing is
that party could have been for like they
just they just like closed a major deal
it could have just been a sell any
celebratory after
hours party it didn't have to be a
christmas party
in order to facilitate the rest of the
plot
that plot still can happen
even if the movie even isn't set at
christmas all that changes is
superficiality
now i have no problem with watching it
as a christmas movie
as certainly as alternate viewing uh
if you don't take or need a break from
more traditional christmas
cool go for it but if you're asking if
you're if you are
pushing me against the wall hand at my
throat no
sorry um and asking me is it a christmas
movie the answer is no
ah let's see
oh my goodness okay so somebody in the
discord answered that said yes best
christmas movie ever next to
jim carrey's how the grinch stole
christmas all right morgan i don't know
if you're in the live chat
well we're gonna have to have words i
think
uh is batman returns a christmas movie
no no
die hard is more of a movie than batman
returns is and i don't think die hard's
a christmas movie either so there you go
uh see like some people really seem to
go just because it's
set at christmas makes it a christmas
movie no
that's not enough like just because a
movie has
parts that make you laugh doesn't make
it a comedy
there are hilarious lines in dramatic
heavy tragic
horrific movies they're not comedies
all of a sudden just because it made you
laugh with the one line it's not a
christmas movie
just because of the timing
it has to do with something that runs
deeper than that for you to call a film
a comedy
and that is how i approach what i call a
christmas movie
all right uh is nightmare before
christmas a christmas movie or halloween
movie
it is a christmas movie except for the
opening number you want to play that at
halloween
go nuts um
is gremlins a christmas movie yes that
one
is because the impact of christmas
actually runs pretty deep in that one
and there there are fairly significant
things you would have to change
to remove christmas from that movie iron
man 3 i forgot iron man 3 was set at
christmas so i'm going to say no
is that what most of the discord is is
this a christmas movie is this not i
haven't seen it for years but i wonder
how trading places holds up
that is definitely a christmas movie
um i debate i
i don't know if it is like
the stuff that happens around christmas
uh certainly has some impacts on some of
the iconography
like that one i feel like's right on the
fence
because while christmas is significant
in that movie i don't know if it's
persistent enough across the film
as to whether or not it holds up for the
most part it does
until the scene on the train with dan
aykroyd in blackface
that part does not hold up
at all rest of it pretty well actually
sorry that this is taking um
longer than usual there's way more
comments in the discord than is standard
oh i should not have down the rest of
that that fast
hello uh let's see
uh somebody posted a link to an article
on some seven films that may or may not
be christmas movies
um i'm
i'm not sure that i'm gonna go
read an article um
but that'll be something for me to check
out later
uh who in the world watches die hard too
um not me
there are only two die hards there's die
hard and there's die hard with a
vengeance
okay i think i'm caught up cool give me
a second
popping back okay when should we expect
the owl house review in the break room
you mentioned earlier
i've shot it i need to edit it but right
now i'm devoting my editing time to
to stuff that like i definitely have a
deadline on so
i don't know i have shot it i need to
edit it
and time is not on my side with a lot of
stuff right now
uh okay uh i feel like
i'm the person who never watched
christmas movies or specials
i've seen the doctor who's specials but
that's about it i mean
to each their own fair enough
did you know there's an 18 movie with
liam neeson and bradley cooper
it's a boss of all action movie and i
love it i knew it existed
i've never seen it uh favorite and least
favorite fantasia segments favorite's
probably knight on ball mountain
least favorite ave maria honestly
i mean it's a good way to come down
after bald mountain but take it as a
segment in and of itself is boring
uh best actor to best actor to play
santa
ooh nick frost why not
to be fair die hard and iron man 3 also
have themes that christmas movies share
with family connections uh
and the like which gives them a bit of a
boost in terms of christmas status
i suppose but it's not like those themes
are unique to christmas
you know what i mean i mean he's there
to try and get back with his wife it's
going to have a familial connection
thing no matter when you said it
i've always been forgiving to loving
monsters but rewatched it the other day
and learned there's
actually a lot more wrong with it than
just a bad monster design
no kidding
like there is a kernel of an idea at the
heart of love and monsters
that i can get behind but nothing about
the execution
works on that
uh i was telling you that you will hate
rachel berry from glee she has
no redeeming qualities whatsoever i'll
just take your word on that
would you ever watch hell of a boss
by visi pop
i don't know what like half those words
were
i probably not do you plan to see wolf
walker soon yes but that's another one
i'm gonna watch with my kid because i
know she's gonna
love it um how about brian blessed a
santa what was he santa in
or is that a theoretical casting did you
know there's an
indian miniseries of stephen king's it
i think i'd heard that
i don't i don't know if i actually did
know that though
have you seen the snowman with the david
bowie intro
nope i'm going to go to bed thank you
for a wonderful stream as always okay
sweet dreams thank you for joining
uh have you seen the eurovi eurovision
the story of fire saga i
only know that eurovision exists that's
where
it begins and ends for me
the one saving grace of earnest saves
christmas is douglas seal as santa
i've heard that i'm not gonna watch it
uh if you ever met someone who likes and
defends
cuties what will you say to them i don't
know because i haven't seen the movie
like don't ask me for an opinion on
something that seems to have a
really heated conversation around it
that i haven't seen
and to be clear i also don't plan to see
it but like i'm
i'm not wading into that
no no
no what the hell was that
what am i doing okay i'm tipsy that's
what that's what that was
there are fans in the doctor who corner
of instagram that legitimately believe
um hold on that legitimately believe
love and monsters is a masterpiece i
don't uh
i don't like to flat-out hate on
opinions but boy
i feel like most of the arguments i've
seen
in in defense of
love and monsters are defending the
concept
and not doing a very good job of
defending the episode itself
but like i said i can get behind the
core idea
but the execution is just garbage i'm
sorry it is
and funnily enough i'd like i feel like
that's a fairly standard refuge
a lot of times with
me entertainment that doesn't work
people who
like it and i'm not saying is
necessarily this is the reason they like
it but they
tend to have a go-to defense of
defending the ideas behind
the movie or the show you know
defending what it was trying to say and
not dealing with what it actually ended
up as
defense defenses of batman v superman
really fall under this category
i've seen defenses and they all seem to
be based around
but it's doing this idea i'm like okay
but it did that idea badly
it doesn't matter what the idea is if
you
uh fail try to find a different f word
if you fail to deliver it doesn't matter
how good the idea was
bing crosby and rosemary clooney and
white christmas is my all-time favorite
class i call it a movie do you have one
i do like white christmas i actually
like white christmas a lot
um i'm more partial to uh
to danny k in that one though personally
rosemary clooney's great though
um i don't watch a lot of the
quote-unquote classic
christmas movies um like i think i've
only seen
um it's a wonderful life once
it was fine but like i didn't grow up on
it so it's not part of my
own tradition you know
holiday movie rotation is there an
animation style you want to see again
because it's
so uh interesting and unique
um
well i mean my go-to answer for that is
i actually can see again and that's the
animation style behind secret of kel's
wolf walkers which is now out but i
haven't seen yet and i want to
um like it's gorgeous i absolutely love
that animation style
to pick something that i haven't seen
done too many times since then there's
something really unique
about the animation techniques or at
least the combination of animation
techniques
that was used by the animated version of
the max maxx
for mtv back in the 90s
because it took some of the techniques
of anime but is the only example that
i can think of off the top of my head
there may be others if there are i have
not encountered them
it's the only example i can think of of
the top of my head that took
anime techniques
but did not include anime stylization
in the design because the design is
completely its own thing
but it absolutely takes a lot of
playbooks from anime
in terms of like having um somebody
standing there and
the character for the most part does not
move it's like it's a locked off image
and to save um money
the only thing that's animated is the
mouth and maybe like the hair and the
wind
they make deliberate choices to animate
fewer elements
which is a technique largely borrowed
from anime as a budget saving cost
but that means that the stuff that they
do animate
uh flows more naturally and moves
nicer because they're animating fewer
pieces and like i said it doesn't adopt
anime
style and i really love that combination
i never realized how problematic the
ending to idiot's lantern was until your
video
like oh my god rose needs a good talking
too yeah
yeah i feel like sometimes some of the
things i get up i get hung up on
and people didn't realize i end up
ruining stuff for people but
yeah no seriously
rose get a therapist
for me it's the style of osamu
tazuka the guy who made astro boy well
yeah that's sort of the
epitome of that style do you know the
lyrics to your mean one mr grinch
yes but not all of them
um because the the
so the version i had of that movie was
taped off of
tv and it had a slightly shortened
version of that song
to make room for more commercials so
there's like
there's one verse that i don't
know very well that's from the like the
proper full version of the song
but the rest of it i know
you're a mean one mr
grinch can't keep singing unfortunately
but yeah
it's nice it's nice to remind myself
that i'm a baritone sometimes
[Music]
the three words that best describe you
are as follows
and i quote stink stank
stunk ah
let's see
i had a super chat here we go from
i don't know i don't know if that's even
meant to be spoken out loud makeup tips
for newly out gender fluid person
all right start simple and when i say
simple
the basics to start with lipstick
eyeliner eyeshadow
basically for eyeshadow is you do two
different
shades the darker shade goes on the lid
the lighter shade goes in the upper part
um
do do not do uniform top to bottom
unless you're going goth and doing black
all the way up
um and never do the darker shade on top
i mean
i say never there are probably times you
can make that look work but that's like
advanced stuff
do not buy a crap ton of makeup
at the start master a couple of things
initially get used to lipstick master
lipstick and i'm going to recommend
getting honestly cheap makeup
to learn with don't go springing for
like the really
nice um stains that like stay for a
while and like
you're just gonna burn through it
through the aggravation especially
i love lip stain i love it a lot and and
color stay things but you don't want to
mess with that until you know
you're putting it on in a shape that
you're going to want because trying to
fix that stuff it's a pain in the butt
but if you start with relatively cheap
makeup
just so you can get used to the process
of putting it on
before you start spending more money on
it i'm not going to give a lot of tips
on foundation
a because i don't use it very much
anymore um
and b i always felt like i there were a
bunch of things that i should have been
doing
with my foundation that i wasn't so i
don't really feel all that qualified to
talk on that topic
but st start with lips
start with eyes be patient start
cheap and fine tutorials is 50 million
of them
again try and start basic don't don't
don't start with like drag queen makeup
tutorials
you will get discouraged i can't do that
crap
favorite studio ghibli film my neighbor
totoro
thoughts on the motion capture animation
style used in polar express and the jim
carrey
christmas carol pointless absolutely
pointless
what is the point of
bringing animation up to the point that
it practically looks like
live action at that point just shoot
live action
what is the freaking point
see i say that i know the point the
point is it gives the director more
direct control over everything that's
going on but like
it ain't worth it counterpoint to your
earlier argument since it starts on
halloween and ends on christmas
thus kind of falling in the middle
nightmare before christmas is a
thanksgiving movie
[Laughter]
just because if it deals with both
doesn't mean that any part of its
structure lands in the middle but i
appreciate your argument do you like
rock and if so what band or artist
i don't pay attention to what
genres of music anything i listen to is
i mean if i if i were to look it up i'd
probably find most of the stuff i listen
to is pop
i like some classic rock like i like the
stones i like queen
i like the beatles um i like fleetwood
mac
i don't know what's going on in rock
right now i feel like everything went
hard and like it all turned into metal
and
which i'm very picky about
let's see
now you think it would be better if
series nine ended with face the raven
and twice upon a time was replaced
with a slightly altered heaven sent
no i would still put heaven sent after
face the raven but i would just change
the ending so it does
lead into hell bent and then we don't do
hell bent and we just scrap
twice upon a time and have the um
have the twelfth doctor regenerate at
the end of the doctor falls which is
really what should have happened
not that i dislike twice upon a time i
actually don't i
i'll go to bat for it as a piece in and
of itself but
it's a weaker sign off than the doctor
falls like
significantly weaker as an exit point
how to best handle broad shoulders with
mtf clothing um sleeveless
that's that's gonna be your big thing is
um
is getting stuff that's sleeveless which
is why
dresses and tank tops are a lot of my
go-to
stuff um if i were to show you my closet
of more feminine stuff
it's pretty much all like strap or
sleeveless
or even like t-shirts or what have you
like some of the sweaters are longer
but like you can go oversized on a
sweater and not have it look
weird the way going oversized on a shirt
does um that's going to be the main
thing
to counteract broad shoulders avoid
something that's going to cling to them
excuse me if you have brick box you need
to watch spitting image somebody else
mentioned that i feel like last um
stream i don't know anything about that
one
heaven's sent should have been the
finale to series nine yes yes it should
have
what's worse series seven or series
eleven
i don't know i don't know because
they're the problems with each one are
very very different and so i feel like
you're splitting hairs about which you
personally think is
a bigger issue having a
badly disjointed series that doesn't
flow worth a
dang or just having a majority of meh
episodes and i
don't know an answer right now
uh something i tend to do because i'm
autistic
i take a lot of things very literal so
the concept of gender fluid always
confused me
on a biological standpoint
uh uh sometimes the terms we use
can be confusing thoughts on polar
express and the jim carrey christmas
carol i'm not a huge fan of either i've
seen
both well i think i've seen uh polish
press maybe twice seen jim carrey
christmas carol once
i don't need to see either of them again
i think toast and coal would be good as
the
geeky technical one of hans gruber's
gang
if they did a prequel movie starring
benedict cumberbatch's grouper
you've really you've uh you've put a lot
of thought into that
they're not talking about doing that are
they
dear god i hope not
uh let's see so many of the best
uh classic bands in metal bands uh is
that they're dying literally
i mean yeah happens to the best of us
and the worst of us eventually it is the
true equality
death is the one thing that is truly
properly democratic
everybody gets to do it you
only get to do it once it's the same for
everybody
am i late are you late i'm thinking
about wrapping up soon so
yeah a little bit
have you seen anna and the apocalypse
it's a zombie christmas musical movie
and it works surprisingly well i've
heard of it i have not seen it
favorite sonic screwdriver um
mine
i just like an excuse to show this thing
off thank you microraptor uh i like
to joke that the reason i'm pan is
because my adhd makes it hard to focus
on
one gender okay look
serious conversation about that
i don't think that my adhd
is the cause of my gender fluidity
however i do think it is a factor
in my inability to commit to any one
thing
in a lot of areas of my life including
my gender
including my sexuality including my
creative outlets
including some no i'm not gonna go there
but there's a lot of elements of my life
that i'm like
i dabble in five million things rather
than pick one and go like that's
my thing and i think adhd has an effect
on that
or is at play at least a little
any thoughts on blacklist never watched
it huey lewis
uh technically should have two oscar
nominations scenes as ray parker jr
ripped him off
uh you can only choose one queen or the
rolling stones queen
uh wait how do you get the sonic
screwdriver how do you get your own
sonic screwdriver
um you pay
somebody uh an embarrassing amount of
money to make you a custom one
and uh etsy is a wonderful place my
friends
so yes this sonic screwdriver
is mine this is my doctor's
sonic screwdriver i love this thing
uh it's got i got it's so bright you
can't see it so well but
see if i can
well it's got you know cogs and gears
and
it's got just um just a little strip of
circuitry on it just
hanging off the side it looks cobbled
together which i love
that to me is part of the appeal of a
sonic screwdriver i don't like a sonic
screwdriver that's too sleek i think
that
might ultimately be part of my issue
with
this one it feels like it came off an
assembly line and obviously like it did
in terms of it's a toy that came off in
an assembly line but
uh this one i think more than any other
just feels
stamped out it is one of the elements i
kind of like about
this one because it feels more cobbled
together
feels more unique and that is absolutely
what i love
about mine because this absolutely like
it
looks like it was thrown together in a
hurry
i love that
next movie live stream you should watch
theodore rex
and i will make dinosaur puns pay me
i will not watch that movie without
being paid
second favorite sonic uh
probably matt smith's um just
just because i like i like that it does
more than just glow
i like the additional action of that and
that it's more and like because
tens extended as well but there's just
something
there's a nice punctuation to that which
i really appreciate
okay let's see
what element would you bend and where
did you get your pride ring
this okay so this is actually my second
one
this somebody sent me because my
original one cracked
that one i got at a uh
at a vintage store
i don't know where the person who sent
me this one
found it because i have looked because
when my first one cracked
i looked for the same thing and i
couldn't find it anywhere
so i don't know where this one
specifically came from but whoever did
send it to me
thank you um
what color lightsaber would you have
um
dark purple not the sort of magenta but
a dark
purple like maybe there's a hint of red
behind it
thoughts on the second dr sonic what you
mean the pen light
um i'm kind of scared to ask
but are you a gamer and if so what genre
do you like i am not a gamer
um i was once upon a time i grew up on
video games i
talked earlier about getting my my
nintendo um
at christmas and you know i stuck i had
a super nintendo had an n64
bought a playstation with my own money
that was the first um
gaming console that i bought for myself
with my own cash
um playstation 2 gamecube
and that was about where i kind of
stopped the only reason i have a ps3 was
that was a christmas present
but that's also where i stopped because
initially i just didn't have the time
the free time and i still don't
uh to be completely honest about it
that's part of
there's a there's a there's a three
factor
reason why i am not currently a gamer
one i can't afford it
two i don't have the free time
to properly enjoy it even if i could
afford it and
three i'm a bit too disgusted with
too much of what goes on in the video
gaming industry
to comfortably partake in current
generation stuff
that having all been said
if and when i eventually replace my
laptop because i'm going to have to at
some point
i may may
indulge indie pc gaming
so you know i mean like undertale's the
obvious go-to but things
like that or um return of the oberdin
was
one that i'd be interested to play or
disco elysium
you know things made by smaller teams
that aren't the
aaa video game sector and that are gonna
run
on a machine that i'm going to have to
own anyways because i need a computer to
do this job
that's the one that's maybe
may be where i ease back into gaming
no promises at all on this
uh the doctor is a witch king
uh hades is great since it was made
without crunch
i i have played um
bastion from that um same developer
because i could get that game on my
phone it's great
so yeah i would love to play their other
games because they've got
transistor and hades and pyre
and i'd be down for playing any or all
of them favorite board or table top game
i'm a fan of the unlock series ooh okay
oh well i mean i'm i'm a dnd gamer so i
do enjoy that if we're talking board
games i don't know
i feel like i'd probably get more into
some of the more recent elaborate stuff
i just haven't played a lot of it
spitting image is a satire show using
puppet caricatures of celebrities and
politicians
i feel like it's gonna grade on me i
might still give it a shot at some point
you'll probably have to keep reminding
me but uh i think you would
uh like abzu if you went if you went
back into games very pretty
you know it was a game that i loved that
did run on my ps3 i love journey
journey was gorgeous
oh thank you so good
favorite subtle joke and die hard is
when one of the terrorists brings ellis
a can of coke
because they obviously misunderstood him
that's a good point theodore rex will
drive you wild
i think i need to do this with these
glasses i feel like these are the
perfect
frames for glaring over them at somebody
uh i am i am going to wrap it up soon
i've run long
uh as much as the cause thing is a joke
i
agree that it probably influenced both
my sexuality and trans identity
yeah honestly i think that's that's fair
i mean in general
there is a higher percentage
um of
neurodiversity a near i'm sorry
neurodivergence
in the uh trans and lgbtq plus
community than there is in the cis
hetero community
not high enough a percentage for it to
be like it's the cause but like
it it happens at a higher rate by most
uh accounts that have studied both
uh does total recall count as a corn
flakes commercial yes it does
okay i do need to wrap up you make all
gl
eyeglasses framed shady
there are some naughty naughty people in
the chat tonight
we may have to go around back
to my office have a long talk
about your behavior
[Music]
why don't you watch the mandalorian
because i'm not comfortable looking at
um oh god
why rosario dawson and
look i say that knowing
that the charges were
they weren't charges they weren't even
criminal i i am aware of the fact
that the uh lawsuit was dropped
i am aware of that so i'm not
saying that i still think she did the
things that she was accused of
i'm not saying that no one else should
watch it but i still don't feel
comfortable
watching her yet and i think
what needs to happen for me is there
needs to be probably honestly
a year
between now and when i'll be comfortable
and in that year
nothing else needs to have happened
because i feel like what went on with
jk rowling has really put me on high
alert
so when something like what happened
with rosario dawson
happens even if later indications are
okay it probably wasn't what it looked
like
part of me still gonna be nervous for a
while
because i'm gonna be wondering in the
back of my head
is this gonna turn out to be the warning
the early warning sign
that a lot of us ignored like
back when jk rowling liked
transphobic tweets and followed a
transphobic person on twitter
there were defenses to be made but in
hindsight we can go back and go those
were the early warning signs
and i need enough time to pass
with someone like rosario dawson where
nothing new has come
up where i can be comfortable thinking
okay it wasn't
an early warning sign now
i'm going to be comfortable and that's
the thing i'm not
saying that there that this should apply
to anyone else
anyone who wants wants to watch the
mandalorian i'm not going to question
your stance as either trans yourself or
a trans ally or anything
i'm not comfortable yet i hope i will be
i've liked rosario dawson as an actress
for a very
very long time
but i'm not comfortable not yet
so
that's why she's in one episode skip it
no i'm not going to kneecap my ability
to appreciate a piece of artwork
like that i would rather wait i would
rather wait till i am comfortable to
enjoy it on its own terms
and if i never get comfortable i will
never watch it
i'm at a point where my
entertainment is not more important
than the impact of
the people involved in it this is why
my harry potter stuff isn't up anymore
and so like for instance i'm going off
on tangents now but
it this is what's happened roll with me
i there are a number of creators on tick
tock
who do um hogwarts
comedy stuff mainly and it's great
i love it and pretty much all of them
have at some point trust me i went back
and looked
before i like started following any of
them
they have disavowed
rowling's beliefs
but the thing is and while i'm not
saying this to shake a finger at anybody
the reason i still won't make that
content
even though part of me would like to
is because i would be
bolstering the profile
of the very influence that she is now
wielding
against people like me
and i'm not okay doing that just so i
can
have fun
i think part of that's age
there was a
time when i would have been one of those
people who said i'm just here to have
fun why do i have to think about this
other stuff
but you know i'm going to be 40 in less
than
a year and a half i'm
i don't have the excuse of youth to keep
thinking that
and i'm not okay with that thought
process certainly for myself
anymore
it the time has come for me to put my
money where my mouth is
and if the people behind a piece of
media even one that i really really love
are hurting and harming people
through the influence that they garnered
from that kind of work
i don't feel comfortable hiding behind
the excuse of
but it's just entertainment it's just
for fun
because with someone like jk rowling we
see the we see what happens
when creators choose to wield the
influence that they
get from the high profile we
grant to their work and to them
and different people's level of comfort
with all this is going to vary
not everyone's going to have the same
level of discomfort that i
do and that's okay
but i don't have much use for the
it's just meant to be fun
you don't have to think about this other
stuff i i can't go there anymore
i do have to think about it i'm too old
and i'm too aware of the world to not
so there we go
you do what's good for you that's that's
what i try and do
i do my best i am not a perfect human
being
um
but you know i try
that's all i can do that's all anybody
can do
don't tell me your office is sound proof
i doubt you will ever have the
opportunity to find out it always makes
me uncomfortable when i see
rowling's books both new and old still
for sale in my local bookstore
yeah yeah that's kind of where i'm at
too if there's one game dev i like
because of their attitude to make a
video game is platinum games and uh who
made bayonetta yeah i've heard good
things about them
people who say it's just for fun don't
seem to complain when people get
emotional value from movies for less
controversial reasons
i mean the thing about the it's just for
fun is it's ultimately
a self-serving justification it's
i want to keep enjoying the thing i
enjoy
and not grapple with the ramifications
of my enjoyment of it
and i get that as an instinct i
absolutely understand that
but that's
really immature
and the amount of slack i'll cut
somebody making taking that position is
honestly
going to vary a lot depending on how old
they are
anybody my age certainly anybody older
people in their 20s depending on how
much of a
dick they are about it
but yeah where do you get all your cool
glasses frames
zeni optical z-e-n-n-i not a sponsor i'm
just a fan
uh completely fair enough anyway have a
good night and a great christmas yeah i
need
i need to wrap this up uh should we feel
more more
represented by the fact that we're not
denied anymore
um
i don't know who the we is in that
statement if you mean lgbtq plus groups
in general
um the absence of denial of your
existence
is not the same as representation it's a
step towards representation but no they
do not equate
okay stop adding me you like you people
have figured me out that my eyes
zero in on the on when you at me and i i
like i have to
ah um i'm putting my hand up so i don't
see
the chat i need to stop i need to go out
a night
thank you all very much for joining me
i hope that you have a wonderful rest of
the month
i hope whatever holidays you choose to
celebrate
you celebrate them safely and lovingly
and communicate however you have to with
the people who matter to you
we won't be speaking again until after
christmas
but that means that i will do
an unboxing for whatever has been sent
to me by whoever felt like sending me
stuff because it seems to happen around
the holidays from time to time
um of course i say that watch it turn
out i don't get enough stuff to have it
be worth an unboxing and i just look
like a
fool regardless
i hope that you all have a wonderful
holiday season you're beautiful
oh you know what
you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
i am just running the meetings
and until next time this council has
adjourned
recovery